Speaker of the House Paul Ryan steps
down the Trump probe pushes the
president toward precipitous action and
James commis book is a-comin we'll have
all of it is the Ben Shapiro show so we
do have a lot to get to today we will
get to all of it in just a second first
I want to say thanks to our sponsors
over at Legal Zoom so it is a fact of
life
attorneys are really really expensive I
know because I am one you're likely to
pay up around 300 bucks an hour for even
a mediocre to decent attorney there is
just one reason why smart business
owners turned to Legal Zoom over 2
million Americans have used Legal Zoom
to start their businesses with LLC's and
corporation and more but even after your
business is set up Legal Zoom can still
help you out things like lease
agreements changing tax laws contract
reviews all of these things are part of
owning your own business as you know if
you own your own business but these are
precisely the kinds of legal hurdles
that take time and money away from
growing your own business which is why
Legal Zoom has actually created
something new it's called their business
legal plan with it you get legal advice
for your business from vetted
independent attorneys and tax
professionals available in every state
you also receive access to NDA's lease
agreements and more and the best part is
that you're not gonna get charged by the
hour since Legal Zoom is not actually a
law firm so you're not gonna be shelling
out $2000 for a contract when you don't
have to instead you pay just one low
upfront price check out Legal Zoom is
misleading and legalzoom.com now and get
special savings when you enter Ben at
checkout legalzoom.com and as her Ben at
check out Legal Zoom is where life meets
legal legalzoom.com and again and her
pro enter code Ben at checkout you can
check out some special savings on their
business legal plan it really is
fantastic because you know for most of
the time legal zann's been around you've
really been using it for wills and
trusts in sort of simple forms but now
you can actually use it for legal advice
itself and around those law firms and
save yourself time and money
legalzoom.com and use that promo Cabana
check out for some special savings and
also to let them know that we sent you
okay so Speaker of the House Paul Ryan
is now out and what's been fascinating
to see is how the left and how the media
have reacted to Paul Ryan leaving so for
a long time they were looking at Paul
Ryan as though he was the future of the
party who is the alternative to trump
and there are a lot of people who are
who are thinking that this was a trump
Ryan battle that was the battle that
really mattered now listen President
Trump won the presidency and that battle
ended in a certain way with a reproach
mount which is that President Trump was
going to be the added
to the party and Paul Ryan was going to
be the idea man of the party and that's
essentially how things worked for the
first year because let's be real most of
trumps sort of heretical priorities you
know the things like trade Wars or
infrastructure plans those things didn't
go anywhere with Paul Ryan in the house
the stuff that actually did move were
some regulatory reform measures or the
tax cuts the the the the attempt to the
attempt to restructure entitlements in
in the tax bill right all of that was
Paul Ryan stuff so what you actually got
was Paul Ryan type governance in many
areas and Donald Trump style rhetoric
that was the sort of agreement that
Republicans came to but with Ryan out
now what you're seeing is an attempt to
recast this entire battle as a battle
between Ryan and Trump even though Ryan
was actually pushing a lot of trumps
priorities and Trump was signing a lot
of Ryan's priorities that doesn't make a
whole hell of a lot of sense and this
miss Reid I think is an attempt to paint
everyone in the Republican Party has
sort of beholden to everything bad about
Trump see this is the goal of the left
now so I've tried to do this in 2016 by
calling everybody a deplorable who
supported President Trump now what
they're attempting to do is they're
attempting to say that anyone who even
tangentially worked with President Trump
actually made a Faustian bargain with
President Trump this is the tenor of the
media coverage and I don't think that
that's correct I don't think it's a
Faustian bargain at all to say listen I
don't like president Trump's character I
don't like what he's been doing on
character but I like a lot of his policy
doesn't seem like a Faustian bargain at
all that seems like normal politics on a
pretty daily basis in Washington DC
where everybody sucks and where the
politics is what matters in the end the
policy is what's supposed to matter in
the end
but Paul Ryan was asked about this by
Jake Tapper Tapper on CNN said to Ryan
you know did you make a Faustian bargain
with President Trump I'm really proud of
the accomplishments we have here and so
I don't see this as some Faustian
bargain devil's bargain or whatever it
is you call it I see it is the country
said go fix these problems you guys get
the majority in the House you get them
during the Senate here's the presidency
now go do something with it that's what
we're doing that's not devil's bargain
that's actually doing what the people in
this country asked us to do and keeping
our word and I'm very proud of that I
mean I'm wondering what exactly the
media mean when they say things like
devil's bargains they mean that Paul
Ryan has not been critical of Trump on
character grounds because that's not
true do they mean that Paul Ryan has
sometimes soft pedaled those character
criticisms in order to get
policy done maybe that's true but he's
also working with a Republican he's
working with the president in his own
party and he has to keep his eye on the
prize when it comes to policymaking
which after all is his job as Speaker of
the House tapri continue to push Ryan on
this on CNN yesterday saying does Trump
embarrass you I know after the Access
Hollywood tape came out in October 2016
mr. Trump was asked not to appear at an
event for you now it's back in the news
in a major way this this must bother you
Access Hollywood stormy Daniels Karen
McDougal at a certain point it must be
embarrassing well what I don't even read
the article I mean I'm obviously
familiar with what you're talking about
so we're pretty focused on just getting
our work done here and so this is
something that I like you guys
speculate about right now I'm busy
trying to get things done in Congress
we've got a big agenda here and so
that's kind of where my focus is and I
don't really have much Punda tree to
offer you on this and look I just think
the way the president ought to handle
this is compartmentalize it and focus on
doing your job we've got issues with
Syria we've got a balanced budget
remember passing this week we've got a
lot to do and that's what I'm focused on
so here's what's hilarious about this
basically if you're Paul Ryan and you're
just a guy who's trying to get an agenda
through you're just trying to get some
things done you're getting ripped by the
right as somebody who's not sufficiently
supportive of President Trump even while
you're pushing president Trump's agenda
and you're being ripped by the left for
not going out there and ripping Trump
every day well for Paul Ryan and for a
lot of other Congress people who I'm
talking to in Congress Trump is not the
top of their priority list
they weren't elected 10 15 20 years ago
to be beholden to Trump nor were they
elected 10 20 30 years ago in order for
them to shift their entire schedule of
their day around reacting in the media
to what President Trump does either
negative or positive and so you know
when Paul Ryan says listen I'm gonna
keep my nose to the grindstone and do
what I'm supposed to do he gets ripped
on both sides it's pretty astonishing
it's pretty astonishing and I think
Meghan McCain made a really good point
yesterday so Meghan McCain obviously is
a John McCain's daughter and yesterday
on the view there are a bunch of people
who are all the left was cheering Paul
Ryan being leaving a Speaker of the
House oh it's just so great that Paul
Ryan is out because Paul Ryan is a shill
and Paul Ryan hasn't stood up to Trump
and all the rest of the stuff all the
same Democrats who never stood up to
Bill Clinton or Hillary Clinton one iota
and now it's about Paul Ryan who didn't
stand up to Trump even though during the
election psych
Paul Ryan actually did stand up to
then-candidate Trump in the middle of
the election cycle and disinvited him
from a particular event after the Access
Hollywood tape and told all the members
of his Republican caucus that he wasn't
gonna be openly campaigning for Trump up
till the election right but but this was
not enough for the folks on the left
they say that you know they're really
happy that Ryan is going and making
McKenna makes a good point she's listen
if Ryan is not sufficient for you in
terms of his sort of tenor then why
exactly wouldn't people vote for
President Trump are the worst kind of
politicians then you deserve Trump
because he is not he's a truly decent
man that was trying to fight for
democracy and conservative ideals and
now what's gonna be left I have no idea
okay good for Megan McCain this is
exactly right when Megan McCain is
saying here's exactly right you know the
left sits around they wonder how did we
get Trump how do we get Trump by calling
Paul Ryan the worst by calling Mitt
Romney the worst by suggesting that
people who are decent were actually bad
and then you know what the right did
they said well maybe it was their
decency that lost them the election
maybe what we need is an indecent man
who punches in order to win an election
and then Trump won on exactly that basis
and then you're wondering why the right
has resonated to president Trump you're
seeing this sort of coverage across the
across the spectrum from folks on the
left
Tim Alberta who actually used to work at
National Review so he's not a left
winger but he writes now for Politico
and he has a whole article called the
tragedy of Paul Ryan he began as a Jack
Kemp conservative he ended his donald
trump's man on capitol hill that's not
remotely true he was not donald trump's
man on capitol hill he was trying to
push against a lot of trumpian
priorities it was it was Paul Ryan who
is attempting to to ends around Mitch
McConnell and get some actual things
done now again I'm not a huge advocate
of Paul Ryan and Speaker of the House I
don't think Paul Ryan was the best
Speaker of the House in the world I
don't think that he was the worst
think he was better than John Boehner I
think he was worse than the Newt
Gingrich and I think he's somewhere in
the middle but this this newfound
attempt to paint Ryan leaving is
anything but Ryan leaving because he
doesn't want to be blamed for a blue
wave that is not his fault is I think
revisionist history on both sides so on
the Left they're saying Paul Ryan is
leaving because Trump is taking over the
party
on the right they're saying Paul Ryan is
leaving because Trump has taken over the
party I don't think any of that is true
I mean that's why President Trump was
praising Paul Ryan yesterday because
input in president Trump's view
correctly Paul Ryan was an ally in
helping him push some of his political
priorities then but here's the article
from Tim Albert at Politico he says Paul
Ryan came to Congress as a Jack Kemp
conservative and will depart it's Donald
Trump Republican it's more complicated
than that certainly history requires
nuance and texture but legacies are
reductive by nature the House Speaker
announced his retirement Wednesday
closing a messy and mesmerizing chapter
in the history of the Republican Party
and for the affable Wisconsin kid who
moved to Washington a quarter century
ago eager to make his mark on fiscal
policy the harsh reality is that he
might be remembered more for
accommodating the impulses of the 45th
president than for crafting a
generational overhaul of the tax code
this is a political obituary of Ryan's
own writing his silence in the face of
Trump's indignities and his officer of
his observance of the exquisite
presidential leadership a line that will
live in infamy would be less remarkable
had he not first established himself as
one of Congress's good guys someone who
sense a principle and decency informed
his objections to Trump's candidacy in
the first place indeed the speaker's
habit of turning a blind eye to the
president's behavior is relevant and
revelatory because it was not always so
there was hardly hardly a tougher Trump
critic during the 2016 campaign than
Ryan who felt duty-bound to combat that
candidate's dark rhetoric and the
party's nativist drift yet there has
hardly been anyone soft on Trump since
election day than Ryan who felt
duty-bound to deliver on the policy
promises made to voter voters and
decided that doing so meant ignoring the
ad hominem savaging of private citizens
the hush money paid to porn stars the
attacks on private companies the
attempts to deal with Jinna my's
institutions and the innumerable other
acts for which Barack Obama would have
been impaled by the right this was
Paul's deal with the devil a phrase used
by several of the speaker's conference
in the days following Trump's shocking
triumph so again the idea here from some
of these folks is that presumably I
guess the idea is that that Paul Ryan
should have been out front all the time
spending his time ripping on president
Trump this is this would have pleased a
lot of the folks on the left now listen
I'm in the business of political
commentating this is what I do for a
living and so one of the things I'm able
to do is when I think Trump has done
something wrong I will rip him for it
and when I think President Trump does
something right I will praise him to the
skies and this is something that I am
able to do but I also am NOT in the
position of having to negotiate with
President Trump over policy so to
pretend that Paul Ryan's sole job was to
comment on president from
doings day in and day out is to ignore
the role of the legislature in the in
the process and I think if Paul Ryan
committed any great sin it was not
standing up to Trump and McConnell on
policy not even on Trump's character
listen what I prefer that all
Republicans played the the same fiddle
that I'm playing sure I would prefer
that when Donald Trump does something
bad all Republicans said that's bad and
when Donald Trump does something good
all Republican and say that's good and
that would include legislators but these
are the people who also have to
negotiate with Trump and there is a bit
of practicality that has to take place
here with regard to how you get policy
done that you have promised your own
constituents this may be the last time
in our in our modern history that
Republicans run all the branches of
government and you expect him did Paul
Ryan to blow that on a daily basis by
talking about Donald Trump's dumb tweets
when everybody already knows Donald
Trump's tweets are dumb again the media
are really driving people toward Trump
because a bunch of people on the right
are simply gonna respond to all this by
saying very simply listen you know like
Paul Ryan will give you somebody who
really doesn't care what you think will
give you Donald Trump okay so before I
go any further on this and I want to get
into the continuation of the the probe
into President Trump first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at Tommy
John so Tommy John is the 21st century
clothing company famous for its
unbelievably comfortable men's underwear
and no wedgie guarantee but now they've
come out with their long anticipated
women's line they have the best pair or
ural of aware or it's free guarantee
which means that if it's not the most
comfortable underwear you've ever worn
Tommy John will foot the bill women have
had it just as bad as men when it comes
to underwear if not worse than guys they
have to worry about pinching squirming
tugging and uncomfortable undergarments
well now Tommy John has fixed it they've
reimagined women's underwear with the
same patented designs in fabric
technology that made them a household
name my wife has a couple of parents Ami
Johnson and she thinks they're just
fantastic our female listeners can
experience the fantastic 21st century
comfort I've been talking about with
regard to men's wear now tan women's
wear as well with Tommy John's
luxuriously soft fabrics there is no
rolling no bunching no wedgies no
pilling no visible panty lines and of
course it's all backed by the best pair
she'll ever wear or it's free guarantee
so ladies stop worrying about your
ill-fitting underwear and get some Tommy
John's hurry over to Tommy John comm
slash Shapiro for 20% off your first
order that's Tommy John comm slash
Shapiro for 20% off again Tommy John
comm slash Shapiro and use that slash
capiro so they know that we sent you
again it's the best underwear you'll
ever wear or it's free that is the
guarantee
over at Tommy John's and there's a
reason they have become so wildly
popular and the reason that becomes
wildly popular is because they're
awesome their underwear is just that
good so go check it out Tommy John calm
slash appear he gets once he percent off
again and use that slash appear oh so
they know that we sent you okay so again
I think that the the focus on Paul Ryan
from the left has been Paul Ryan is a
bad guy because you didn't spend enough
time
ripping Trump up and down and then if
you watch Fox News and some of the
commentators on Fox News the problem
with Paul Ryan is that he wasn't
sufficiently obsequious to Donald Trump
you shouldn't spend to all of his time
kissing Trump's ass more well again
talking to the legislators talking to
the legislators I can tell you this
there are a lot of legislators who don't
like President Trump much personally but
they're keeping it under wraps for a
couple of reasons one because they think
that it is counterproductive to rip into
a president they have to negotiate with
and number two because they already
figured that it is well known the
president Trump has some character flaws
that are pretty serious and them
mouthing off about it only allows the
media to use them as a tool against the
Republican Party more generally that's
why I think it's very important to draw
a distinction in our minds in the
conservative movement between our
legislators and our thought leaders
these are not the same people now this
is a broader conversation that that I
think needs to be had who are the
thought leaders inside the Republican
Party who are the thought leaders inside
the conservative movement ever since the
days of Woodrow Wilson there's been an
idea that the president is the thought
leader of the country Barack Obama was
the thought leader George W Bush was the
thought leader Bill Clinton was the
thought leader Ronald Reagan was the
thought leader but the reality is that
the way that the founders drew up the
Constitution that the folks who were
running all of our lawmaking were not
supposed to be the quote-unquote thought
leaders they were supposed to be the
implementer subjects in public well and
that meant that thought leaders were
really supposed to exist in many cases
outside of government and many of the
great thought leaders in American
history where people who never served as
president who barely served in
legislatures Alexander Hamilton was
somebody who never became president
obviously he served inside a couple of
administrations but he was not somebody
who was was going to be President of the
United States Benjamin Franklin another
great thought leader and it there there
are many great thought leaders in
American history and those thought
leaders have been as important or more
important than people who are in
positions of power looking to people
whose job it is to
write and rewrite legislation as the
people who are going to speak to
principle I think is largely a mistake
and it's a mistake also for the base the
reason it's a mistake for the base is
because when you listen to people like
Paul Ryan talk or Mitch McConnell talk
and they talk about philosophy their
philosophy sounds a lot like yours in
the base their philosophy sounds like a
lot like mine this is why when I
interviewed Paul Ryan a couple of weeks
ago and he and I talked conservative
philosophy he sounds exactly like me
with regard to spending priorities and
then a week later he's pushing into law
1.3 trillion dollar omnibus spending
package with which I assume he totally
disagrees why because legislators have
two jobs want us to talk about ideas but
the more important job is for them to
actually get legislation done it is our
job to have the ideas and to hold people
responsible for those ideas so don't
look to politicians for being near
thought leaders don't look to
politicians to be the character
advocates don't look to politicians to
be these guys because they just won't be
I wish they would be I wish that
everyone in politics spent all their
days talking about principle and
worrying about principle and then openly
stating when they were straying from
principle in order to make legislative
gambits but that's not how this works
that's not how this works and blaming
Paul Ryan for how the system works I
think is a mistake and it also leads us
to some pretty stupid conclusions about
the kind of politicians that we should
be electing instead of the kind of
politicians who can get things done and
then it's up to us to toss them out if
they don't get those things done or if
they don't reflect our own ideology okay
meanwhile I'm president Trump's really
really angry he continues to be very
very upset about this FBI probe and we
are now finding out what exactly the FBI
was looking for when it raided Michael
Cohen's office Michael Cohen of course
was president Trump's personal lawyer
and the the personal office of Michael
Cohen was raided by the FBI apparently
one of the things that they were looking
for were documents related to the Access
Hollywood tape so what exactly does
Michael Cohen have to do the Access
Hollywood tape as you recall in the late
days of the election there was a tape
that was broken from Access Hollywood in
which President Trump was caught on a
hot mic talking with Billy Bush and
speaking about how he was a found fan of
grabbing women by the genitals right and
how if they misspell grabbed women by
the genitals they were totally fine with
this and of course this is a big hubbub
and Donald Trump dropped eight to ten
points in the polls and everybody
assumes his electoral chances were over
including me right all of this was it
was a big pop up at the time what is it
Michael Kohn right what does that have
to do with president Trump's lawyer well
the suggestion is now being made and
this if this is really all this is gonna
be honestly if the FBI rated Michael
Kahn on this basis if you have FBI rated
Michael Kohn based on only the stormy
Daniel stuff this is really weak T yeah
but here's what the suggestion is the
suggestion was made by Adam Schiff the
representative from Mac I believe my
district
he made that suggestion he said quote
the reported seizure could be about
whether Michael Cohen was making an
effort to suppress release of that tape
much like he was trying to pay hush
money for these other people stormy
Daniels among others to keep their
stories out of the press during the
presidential campaign and whether that
was violation of the campaign finance
laws not to report it that's one
possibility it's also a possibility that
they're looking at whether the Trump
campaign and Michael Cohen had any role
in the timing of the WikiLeaks of the
Russia stolen Podesta emails you'll
recall that the timeline that day was
the Access Hollywood tapes were released
alike 356 p.m. and 4:30 p.m.
WikiLeaks dropped all of the Podesta
emails and so I guess the suggestion is
now being made by Adam Schiff that
Michael Cohen called up the Russians and
said listen guys I know you're gonna
release the Podesta emails anyway but
it'd be great if you could accelerate
that release that we can have a
counter-narrative I find that
exceedingly hard to believe now it's
quite possible that they're looking for
evidence that Michael that Michael Cohen
who spent a lot of time paying off
various paramours and bad stories for
Donald Trump there's another story like
that from The New Yorker today The New
Yorker printed a story that says that
the National Enquirer paid $30,000 to a
doorman of Donald Trump's who was trying
to sell a story that said that Donald
Trump had fathered a child out of
wedlock in the late 80s no one knows who
that child would be we can all speculate
and and I guess we could we could do
some fun speculation and just pray and
hope that it wasn't Justin Bieber but
what we came but we also know is that
the National Enquirer had had actually
done this to store McDaniels before I
believe or was it was it there's another
Playboy bunny there there was somebody
else that the National Enquirer had paid
for a story I Karen McDougal maybe and
then drop the story and quashed the
story and so there a suggestion that
this was also an in-kind contribution to
the Trump campaign if all that we've got
here is in-kind contributions to the
Trump campaign I don't think that's
enough for impeachment I just don't I
think campaign finance violations are a
big nothing when it comes to the
American public imagination
very few people care about campaign
violations people assume that there is a
lot of corruption with regard to how
campaign finance is done and again the
Obama administration took in two million
dollars in 2008 of illegal campaign
contributions and they ended up paying a
four hundred thousand dollar fine by
2012 there's no suggestion that Trump
that that Obama should have been
impeached over all of that but again
this investigation is certainly a thorn
in the side of President Trump Steve
Bannon is suddenly back right you
remember sloppy Steve and President
Trump now stood him to my great
enjoyment and Steve Bannon who was the
former White House chief strategist who
then went into the into the press and
started ripping on President Trump and
calling him stupid and calling Ivanka
stupid saying she was dumb as a brick
and all this kind of stuff
well now banned in his back and he's
trying to weasel his way back into
Trump's good graces by doing what he
does best
giving unbelievably crappy advice
according to the Washington Post
Steve Bannon has called up Trump and
he's pitching a plan to West Wing aides
to try and end the special counsel probe
to end Robert Muller's probe the first
step would be to fire rod Rosenstein the
rod Rosenstein of course is the Deputy
Attorney General who actually recused
himself and appointed the special
counsel he still has the jurisdiction to
fire Robert Muller but Rosenstein has
been blamed for a lot of stuff by
President Trump so step one be firing
rod Rosenstein step two would be stopped
cooperating with Muller and step three
would be invoking executive privilege
that previous White House staffer
interviews with Muller become null and
void according to ban and so Bannon told
The Washington Post quote the president
wasn't fully briefed by his lawyers on
the implications of not invoking an
executive privilege it was a strategic
mistake to turn over everything without
due process an executive privilege
should be exerted immediately and
retroactively Lee okay well that is not
a possibility okay executive privilege
only applies when you apply it you can't
retroactively lis apply executive
privilege you don't get to just declare
willy-nilly executive privilege on stuff
that's already been turned over to the
FBI
at least that's a difficult legal case
it's abandoned is trying to get Trump to
fire rod Rosenstein which would end in
presumably the the firing of Muller
eventually I'll explain why this is all
a bad idea in just a second first I want
to say thanks to our sponsors over at
trippin comm so if you're planning a
vacation and particularly if you have
kids or even if you don't the reality is
that you don't want to stay in a hotel
room okay hotel rooms I've stayed in
enough of them in my life let me tell
you the
all start to close in and if you have a
kid or more the idea of staying in one
bedroom with your children is not
wonderful what you actually want is
vacation rental these vacation rentals
are just fantastic I've done it with my
wife in Big Bear in Hawaii and it is
just terrific the folks you need to go
to are the folks over at trippin comm
it's one search that lets you compare
every home from the world's top vacation
rental sites in one place to find the
best deal on your perfect vacation
rental vacation rentals do offer more
we're talking more privacy more space
for everyone under one roof you got
washer/dryer soon enough to pack as much
you have a kitchen so you can actually
cook for yourself even hot tubs the
comforts of home and then some
so checkout trippin comm and again they
have rates up to eighty percent less
than traditional hotel rooms so if
you're planning a Spring Break on the
beach in Florida trippin comm is the
place for you or if you can't wait to
swim in Lake Tahoe this summer trippin
comm is for you as well
and if you are just dreaming of sitting
on the deck of a Smoky Mountains cabin
trippin comm can make that happen for
you trippin comms slash shapiro CR IPP
ing comm slash up hero find your perfect
vacation rental trippin comm slash
apparel and as I say trippin comm these
vacation rentals they are significantly
better than hotels that you're gonna
stay and you're gonna stay in a hotel
and you're gonna feel cooped up or you
could have a palatial estate with the
help of trippin comm for vacation
trippin comm / Shapiro check it out we
use it for our vacations and you should
as well okay so again Steve Bannon is
trying to get the president's fire rod
Rosenstein that would be a disastrous
idea and not only that there there are
other folks in the Republican Party who
are doing the same Newt Gingrich I think
made just an asinine statement yesterday
he was talking about this FBI raid on
Michael clones offices now you may not
like the FBI raid on Michael Cohen's
office Alan Dershowitz certainly doesn't
and I think that there's some logistical
reasons why you wouldn't like that raid
you might say well we haven't seen the a
we haven't seen the warrant we don't
know exactly what they were looking for
that seems over broad we have to
carefully protect attorney-client
privilege one of the most amazing things
that I saw yesterday this is really
funny is the New York Times saying why
would try if Trump's innocent why would
he care about attorney-client privilege
okay that's like saying if you if you
don't have anything to hide why don't
you just let the police search your
house every day if you don't have
anything to hide why don't you just make
your walls of glass a maybe because you
actually like your privacy maybe because
there's stuff that Trump has done with
Cohn that's not illegal but that's
embarrassing there plenty of reasons why
you would like attorney
client privilege if you're president
Trump even if they're not trying to
cover up a crime
the New York Times however doesn't
accept that again Alan Dershowitz has
said that he thinks that this this
search was over broad that since we
don't know the basis of the search and
what they're looking for it seems like a
wild jump to allow the FBI to raid the
offices of michael cohen who's the
president's lawyer i know that i know
that there are other talk show hosts
have been suggesting that it may not in
fact even be a campaign finance
violation if the President of the United
States and Michael Cohen were to pay off
stormy Daniels so what exactly would be
the underlying crime nonetheless what
Newt Gingrich says here is so crazy that
it's not good for president Trump's case
here's what Newt Gingrich said about the
FBI search we're supposed to have the
rule of law it ain't the rule of law
when they kick in your door at three
o'clock in the morning and you're faced
with armed men and you you have had no
reason to be told you're gonna have that
kind of treatment that's a that's Stalin
that's the that's the Gestapo in Germany
that shouldn't be the American FBI okay
so no it is not the Gestapo no it is not
Stalin asked this is ridiculous there
was a full warrant process that was gone
through it went to a magistrate judge
went to the US District Attorney in this
in the Southern District of New York who
was a Republican so again all of this is
is overstated now does this mean that
Muller hasn't exceeded his brief here I
think Muller pretty clearly has exceeded
his brief in some ways I do I think that
this this violation of attorney-client
privilege is a wonderful idea I'm not
gonna know that until I see more
evidence I'm happy to wait for more
evidence instead of jumping to
conclusions about where this is going
but one thing is clear you know with all
of the hubbub over it with all the lack
of information it's pretty obvious that
President Trump is getting more and more
agitated about this and you can see that
the media are goading him you can
actually see this if you watch CNN the
media are goading President Trump over
and over and over they're gloating
President Trump right Wolf Blitzer
yesterday was spending most of the day
talking about the president is probably
in the Oval Office fulminating right now
the president is probably in the West
Wing just angry and tweeting right now
you can you and then they would have
full panel conversations on how angry
Trump was which of course is designed to
make Trump angrier because the media
would love nothing better than for
president Trump to fire Robert Muller
you know Whoopi Goldberg sort of let the
cat out of the bag here she explained
yeah you know what I'd love to see this
thing explode
about something that hasn't happened
that's going on a lot of unnamed sources
so I don't think that we should get too
far ahead of our skis I do think
everything you're saying about what
would happen if he does fire molar I've
said Lindsey Graham has said it's
political suicide i 100% think there
would be I think it would actually be
rioting and Washington DC I think it
would be that way that we can't
comprehend since the Nixon era okay
because she says that you would love it
right there that would be what is
looking forward to the riots the left
wants this they want the excuse to
impeach President Trump they want the
excuse to say that this is full-scale
obstruction of justice and that's
another reason why they've been pushing
for example the the James Comey book
which is coming out now Lindsey Graham
gets this right Senator Lindsey Graham
from South Carolina he says to president
from please do not do not fire Muller if
you do that if you fire Muller it's just
gonna backfire on you it's a big mistake
Lindsey Graham is exactly correct about
this even if you if you hate them all
our investigation even if you think them
all our investigation sucks even if you
think that it's all a sham even if you
think they've got nothing on collusion I
think they have nothing on collusion
even if you think that there's no
evidence of criminal activity yet and
I've seen no evidence of actual criminal
activity yet even if you believe all of
that firing Muller is a big mistake as
Lindsey Graham says mr. president car
watching I think you're gonna be fine
unless you screw this up let the process
play out I don't believe you colluded
with the Russians but Muller will soon
tell us the Kohen situation I am
convinced has got nothing to do with
Russia they're trying to squeeze Michael
Cohen in order to and there's all
obviously all kinds of correspondence
that would have related to President
Trump in the time even before he was
running that would be in that office and
the president seems incensed about it
based on what he's right I understand
the president feel like they're getting
out of balance here but I want to tell
you this if Muller was trying to squeeze
Cohen Muller would have done it this is
something unconnected to Russia I'm a
hundred percent convinced of that and
we'll see what Muller finds let him do
his job okay so you know I think that
Lindsey Graham is totally right about
this but again the media are now in the
business of trying to goad President
Trump into making a presidency ending
mistake by firing Robert Muller one of
the other ways they're doing this is by
pushing James Cummings book so let's
start with this James Comey the former
FBI director is indeed a grandstander
president from calton a grandstander
president from suggested
he was in it for the attention James
Comey it's pretty clear is exactly that
he should have been fired after he went
out front and said that Hillary Clinton
did not violate the law even when she
did that was completely inappropriate it
was completely inappropriate for him to
do a full press conference laying out
all the reasons that Hillary Clinton had
committed criminal violations and then
to recommend to the DOJ in order to
cover for then Attorney General Loretta
Lynch and say that she shouldn't be
prosecuted anyway then he came back
about a few days before the election and
he issued a letter about how he had
reopened the Hillary email investigation
essentially and then a couple days later
he shut it down again so again well done
James Comey and then Trump should have
fired him when he first came into office
and said listen this guy's incompetent
this guy obviously loves the limelight
he loves being out front you know this
is this is absurd instead President
Trump kept him around in some sort of
misguided bid for I guess bipartisanship
and then he kept going to James Comey he
kept saying listen you know FBI director
can you just say that I'm not under
investigation and Comey kept saying
you're not under investigation but I'm
not gonna say it and the reason I'm not
gonna say it is because if you do fall
under investigation then I'll have to
announce it and Trump said okay fine so
do that like fine but you say I'm not
under investigation right now like why
is that so tough Comey wouldn't do it to
Trump fired him totally within his
purview okay moe James Comey himself
testified before Congress that his
investigation was not impeded in any way
by President Trump that President Trump
did not act well the president Trump you
know had asked him about loyalty the
President Trump had suggested that he
dropped the investigation Mike limit at
no point had Trump actually exerted
pressure on Comey to do anything right
said a couple of things but that does
not necessarily amount to exerting
pressure especially when he's the
President of the United States and he
can actually do a lot of stuff within
the purview of his executive power in
order to quash an investigation if he
wants to well Comey waits a full year a
full year after his firing and now he's
coming out with this book all about how
honorable and duty-bound he is and now
he'll answer all the questions so we've
been told that he's answer he he was
with it for an hour with George
Stephanopoulos on ABC News and that's
where he's launching his book and we're
supposed to believe that he is some sort
of great honorable figure who's now
going to answer all the questions well
he was in front of Congress and didn't
answer like half their questions so now
all of a sudden he's a great honorable
figure and of course the media are truly
well and good excited about this I mean
they are just there they're sweating
bullets
with excitement over how wonderful this
is going to be I'll show you just how
excited they are in just a second first
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
wire.com and subscribe for $9.99 a month
get a subscription to daily wire when
you do the rest of my show live there's
two clave ins show live the rest of
Knowles's show live and we have other
goodies as well Matt Walsh is doing a
show now so you can check that out too
when you go to daily wire comm all of
that for $9.99 a month plus you get the
rest of you get to be part of the
mailbag tomorrow so if you want to ask
me questions now is the time to
subscribe with your annual subscription
you get all of those things plus you get
this right here
the leftist here is hot or cold tumblr
$99 a year cheaper than the monthly
subscription you will enjoy it and again
we we ask you to subscribe because it is
the best way to help us bring you good
content every single day here at the Ben
Shapiro show you just want to listen
later for free feel free to go over to
iTunes or SoundCloud or YouTube but
please subscribe please leave us a
review it always helps we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
so media are very pumped up of course
about James Comey and James Comey
they're clips now coming out from his
interview with George Stephanopoulos
first of all every time I mentioned
George Stephanopoulos I'm going to say
former Hillary Clinton chief of staff
George Stephanopoulos and George
Stephanopoulos acting as a lead anchor
on a major news network is just insane
it is insipid it's the equivalent of
having Karl Rove anchor coverage on you
know some some tell-all book from the
Obama administration it's just
ridiculous but here's George
Stephanopoulos interviewing James Comey
and Comey doing his righteous
indignation routine how strange is it
for you to sit here and compare the
president to a mob boss this Sunday
night on ABC things that you know but
haven't said they could damage President
Trump
James Comey and to those who say you
should have brought Hillary Clinton
before a grand jury
the exclusive interview everyone will be
talking about this president Trump
obstructing justice should donald trump
be impeached Stephanopoulos Comey
this Sunday night at a special time
10:00 9:00 central on ABC so much are so
much higher loyalty ah you can see
George said I love that promo especially
because all you have are cutaway shots
of Kobe Kobe doesn't say a word anywhere
in there you know he apparently calls
Trump a mob like figure a mob boss
figure well you know again I don't think
that that's wildly unpredictable given
the fact that President Trump's own
Moyer has suggested he is Tom Hagen
right I mean Michael Cohen has said that
he's Tom Hagen to Donald Trump's Michael
Corleone so that's not exactly a shock
in any real sense but the media are very
excited about Comey because what they're
hoping is that again Donald Trump gets
so angry over Comey that he just gets
mad the next day and fires Mullen for no
reason at all the reality is that James
Comey there's so much politics going on
and so little of honor going on it's
pretty insane the media are all so hot
and bothered by the news that the RNC is
going after James Comey in advance of
the release of this book so according to
CNN the battle plan against Comey
obtained by CNN calls for branding the
nation's former top law enforcement
official as lion Comey through a website
digital advertising and talking points
to be sent to Republicans across the
country before his memoirs released next
week the White House signed off on the
plan which is being overseen by the RNC
the chairwoman of the
ta'rhonda romney McDaniel has said quote
Comey is a liar and a leaker and his
misconduct led both Republicans and
Democrats to call for his firing
if Comey wants the spotlight back on and
will make sure the American people
understand why he has no one to blame
but himself for his complete lack of
credibility and they have actually
opened up a site it is called Lyon Comey
coms they've been used using Trump's
appellation for James Comey and it has
quotes from Democrats testifying how
James Comey was unfit for office as well
as explanations for why Trump's firing
with Comey was not obstruction of
justice now the media of course our
treating this is a scandal how dare the
RNC attack Comey
well maybe the artists he's attacking
Comey because Comey is he waited a year
so he got a massive book advance and
then go on a publicity tour to talk
about how much Trump sucks maybe that's
why they're attacking Comey is that
really any sort of shock and again Comey
deserves pretty much every bit of it
Comey has been wildly dishonorable
throughout a lot of this process that
doesn't mean that Trump was smart to
fire him he wasn't it doesn't mean that
Trump was smart and how he fired him he
fired him and then he went on TV two
days later and suggested that the reason
that he fired James call me was because
he didn't like how James Comey been
asking about the Russia investigation
and he used rod Rosenstein the Deputy
Attorney General as cover for the firing
of James Comey requiring rod Rosenstein
to appoint Robert Muller in the first
place so if Trump had never fired Comey
none of this ever happens that said does
James Comey deserve the criticism you
bet your ass he deserves the criticism
hey James Comey is in fact a
grandstander that said is it smart
strategy of the RNC to be parroting
Trump's branding of lion come II know it
makes it look political but they really
should do is they should just say listen
James commis credibility on these issues
has been called into question James
Comey is somebody who likes the
limelight James Comey is somebody who
wants to be in front of the cameras
James Comey could have said all of this
a year ago when it was most relevant he
waited a year to speak it because he
wanted his money and now he's here for
the money he's here for the publicity
and he's here for the money and that is
not unfair by any stretch of the
imagination I want to see a reporter
asked Comey that why is it they wouldn't
answer these questions for a year but
suddenly you want to go around talking
about how James Comey is is the the king
of honor that doesn't make a lot of
sense yeah I said that Newt Gingrich had
said something absurd earlier in the
show but Gingrich said something that's
obviously true as well
he said Comey is in it for the cash I
think that's pretty clear at this point
the objective
as commis off grandstanding and making
money but the truth is that he didn't do
his job in the Bush administration he
colluded with Schumer to embarrass
President Bush the truth is he appointed
a special counsel in the Bush
administration who ran wild and the
truth is he failed to prosecute the
people in the Clinton campaign and I
think we are this we're gonna take this
as a chance to educate the country about
commis okay and I think that that is
exactly right
again all these battles can be fought
but these should be fought by proxy they
should not be done by the President of
the United States himself you'd be
better off being above the fray and
dealing with serious issues that we are
dealing with right now like the
situation in Syria there are people who
are gonna speak out on his behalf when
he deserves it and right now you know it
is fair to say that this Comey attempt
by the media is an area where the
president deserves a certain amount of
defense a certain rational reasonable
defense trotting out the the the lion
combing line I think is
counterproductive okay meanwhile Mark
Zuckerberg was appearing on the hill
yesterday and he got himself in a bit of
hot water Steve Scalise who's the House
Majority Whip maybe the next Speaker of
the House he grilled Zuckerberg on
Zuckerberg the anti conservative bias
over at Facebook I think it's well worth
the watch who develops the algorithm I
wrote algorithms before and you can
determine whether or not you want to
write an algorithm to sort data to
compartmentalize data but you can also
put a bias and if that's the directive
was there a directive to put a bias in
and first are you aware of this bias
that many people have looked at and
analyzed and seen congressman this is a
really important question
there is absolutely no directive and any
of the changes that we make to have a
bias and anything that we do to the
contrary our goal is to be a platform
for all ideas okay well that there is
nonsense obviously the way that you bias
your algorithms is going to determine
which sort of news sources are benefited
in which ones are not and the way that
it is the the proxy for politics in the
new algorithm is established media so
CNN NBC New York Times these are all
being these are all being benefited by
the new algorithm changes over at
Facebook and Zuckerberg is fibbing when
he says that that has nothing to do with
politics okay meanwhile today actually
marks Holocaust Remembrance Day so this
is Yom Hashoah it's the day in Israel
that they do something that's pretty
amazing I think that we should probably
do it in the United States
on Memorial Day as well they actually
there's certain time of the day where
the siren goes off and everyone in the
country literally everyone in the
country stops their cars everybody steps
out of their cars and there's a about a
minute of silence across the entire
country in honor of the Holocaust that
seems to me something we should do in
the United States with regard to our
fallen soldiers but there's a pull out
that really is shocking on how a cost
Memorial Day and that is a pope from the
conference on Jewish material claims
against Germany according this poll only
41% of Americans do not know what ash
whit's was including two thirds of
Millennials approximately 22 percent of
Millennials had not heard of the
Holocaust forty-one percent of
Millennials thought two million or fewer
Jews were murdered during the Holocaust
okay that is a shocking shocking number
these are shocking numbers four out of
ten four out of ten Americans don't know
what Auschwitz was two thirds of
Millennials two-thirds of people aged 18
to 34 don't know what the killing
chambers were in Auschwitz this is it's
it's amazing stuff and again one fifth
of all Millennials have not even heard
of the Holocaust you talk about deficits
in our education system you want to know
why Millennials don't know enough about
politics why Millennials are willing to
go along with the identity politics and
race-baiting of the left you want to
know why Millennials are so fine going
along with the socialism that's being
promulgated by the media well it's
because they don't know anything about
the Soviet Union they don't know
anything about actual Nazi Germany other
than people they don't like are to be
called Nazis they don't know anything
about any of these issues
the way history is taught in our public
schools and in our private schools is
through the Howard Zinn lens you want to
talk about a certain level of
egocentricity egocentricity runs rampant
through Howard Zinn why because his
entire take on history is that America
is responsible for virtually everything
bad and the way that American students
should learn is by learning what America
has done that's wrong now I think that
part of a well-rounded education is
understanding what Americans have done
right and what we have done wrong what
America has done right and what we have
done wrong but if you want to look at
the actual learning of history you have
to look at world history you have to
look at the alternatives to America you
have to look what has happened in other
countries when other systems of thought
have been embraced the Holocaust was not
something that happened in a vacuum the
Holocaust happened because it was
subject to a particularly virulent
strain of a nasty nationalist ideology
combined with a big government ideology
that suggested that a
fascist central governments ought to
ought to make it ought to bind the the
German people together in a sort of
romantic unity there's certain Welton
Shang that that dominated in Germany and
that the government was the was the Fonz
head of all of this that Hitler was the
was the father figure and that he was
the great leader and that all the German
people were going to were going to unite
behind Adolf Hitler and recognize their
own Aryan superiority and then they were
going to and then they were going to
unite in order to make Germany great
again by having Germany essentially run
from the top down and eventually this
culminates obviously in the gas chambers
at Auschwitz now the question is where
does this fit into our modern political
context well it should tell us a few
things it should tell us about the
dangers of a centralised government that
disarms people and then determines that
some people are subjected to different
rules because of their race it should
tell us that identity politics is really
negative and really dangerous and that
judging people by their race and
ethnicity ends poorly it should tell us
that romantic nationalism is not the
same as patriotism that if you are a
patriot you believe in America because
of our ideals and our Creed you don't
believe in America just because of the
people who are here and you certainly
don't believe in America because of
ethnic solidarity and these are the
lessons of the Holocaust but you're not
gonna learn those lessons if you don't
know anything about it and you're
certainly not gonna know anything about
the Middle East if you don't know
anything about the Holocaust you're
going to give a lot of credibility and
credence to groups that openly call for
a second Holocaust I'm talking about
commas and Hezbollah both of which have
been praised by Jeremy Corbyn the
leading figure in the Labour Party in
Britain the possible next prime minister
of that that country you're not gonna
know what that why Israel exists if you
don't understand the threat of
anti-semitism in Europe they're going to
give a lot more credence to the Iran
deal if you don't recognize the
possibility of a second Holocaust this
is something that happened folks this
was not a myth a few years back in 2011
or 2010 I wrote a memoir for helping out
a fellow who had survived the Holocaust
and this memoir was about his survival
at Auschwitz he's actually a cousin of
Elie Wiesel and I can tell you this was
a real thing that happened okay and if
students don't know about it that is a
Shanda right it is a shame it is a
disgrace to our education system and
it's something that needs to be
immediately corrected by an education
system that is failing us on virtually
every level
okay time for a couple of things that I
like and then a couple of things that I
hate so let's begin with a thing that I
like so I've been doing kind of
little-known musical as well I'm
straying from that today I'm doing a
well known musical this is one that your
high school probably produced but I was
really listening to it the other day and
the lyrics are the lyrics particularly
to this musical are just great Guys and
Dolls the movie version is not bad it's
a little long Marlon Brando can't sing
which is a serious problem because the
actual main part should be able to sing
right Sky Masterson should be able to
sing in it but the lyrics are so clever
in Guys and Dolls it's it's really worth
the listen here's of course one of the
famous numbers from I called fugue for
tin horns that's three guys who are
talking about betting on horse racing I
[Music]
got the horse right here
the name is Paul Revere here's a guy can
do
this guy says the horse can't do if he
says the horse can do can't give love
and time cuz I morning line guys got him
at five tonight but by a half going to
this here in the telegram for big Rivera
bite his friends all right a bastard I
read last night it's really fun light
musical and it's worth watching tomorrow
I'll probably do another musical by
Frank Loesser this one's my friend
closer I'll probably do another one
tomorrow by Frank Loesser which I will
tell you about then cuz he wrote like
three or four really really good
musicals so I believe I've done How to
Succeed in Business Without Really
Trying before but there's another one
that people don't know that much about
that was a relatively big hit on
Broadway we'll do that tomorrow okay
other things that I like I just have to
mention this this happened on wheel of
fortune last night this is just this is
so terrible so there's this guy on wheel
of fortune and he has all of the letters
literally all of letters are filled in
okay he there's no way to get this wrong
he has every letter filled in he gets it
wrong anyway he gets it wrong anyway
because what the puzzle says is flamenco
dance lessons flamenco dance lessons the
guy wildly mispronounces it and they do
not give him the answer he gets it wrong
and he loses because he cannot read okay
I'm wheel of fortune so here it is
[Applause]
sorry Ashley it's your turn
I also yeah flamenco dance lessons yeah
that's it and we're gonna there we go
she's got it so to explain what we all
heard was and I know you didn't mean to
say but you gave us a G instead of a see
but we're gonna we'll look at things and
make sure we did things correctly during
our commercial but that's the way it's
been heard everywhere you get $2,000
you'll take a break
Johnny's face Johnny's like what just
what what just happened now pretty
amazing stuff and ashes like Ashley
can't believe it either these are the
two contestants
Pat Sajak can't believe that just
happened so well done everybody involved
yeah we may need to revitalize our
education system for a second reason
namely learning how to read Because Wow
just the thing just think okay so other
things that time for a couple of things
that I hate all right so yesterday
president Trump signed a bill into law
against sex sex trafficking this is not
a thing I hate this is a thing I like
very much here's what it looked like
when President Trump did this yesterday
you'll see a couple of the women
actually dancing as he signs the bill
because it's rather important to have
laws on the books against sex
trafficking of women and children
HR 1865 mister this is landmark
legislation that is truly as the leader
said going to save life and it already
is I received a text message from the
Manhattan da last night that said we
have already shut down eighty-seven
percent eighty seven percent of the
online sex trafficking ads out there
what I want to thank everybody this is
my great honor the I will say the
political people around the desk of
every one of them Democrat and
Republican have worked very hard okay so
this is obviously a good thing well
there is a problem however and that's
that the women's March is very upset
about it so you ask why would the
women's March be in favor of a site that
involves itself in sex trafficking why
would that possibly be the answer is
because the women's March is all stand
also standing up for prostitution
so they tweeted out on April 7 the
shutting down of Backpage is an absolute
crisis for sex workers who rely on the
site to safely get in touch with clients
sex workers rights our women's rights
okay then in the coming days we'll be
sharing more about sex workers rights to
uplift this critical issue we're all
still learning and as always we have
listened to the voices of those most
impacted hashtag sex work is work well
alright but I assume that the women's
marketers would also think that men who
engage in prostitution are disgusting
pieces of human filth which is a
proposition with which I generally agree
so that's a weird statements and you're
in favor of prostitution but you think
the men who engage in it are disgusting
got it also worth noting Backpage itself
is directly linked according to critics
with sex trafficking and sexual abuse of
children Senator Rob Portman said it is
a positive step forward in our efforts
to hold accountable sex traffickers that
sell women and children online Claire
McCaskill is Democrat that she said
state and local law enforcement need
this bill to enable them to take swift
action against websites that knowingly
facilitate sex trafficking of children
online okay so the women's March why
exactly would they be defending this
because the women's March defends the
worst things on earth okay that the
leaders of the women's March has
defended Louis Farrakhan the leaders of
the women's March have been involved
with Planned Parenthood the is it any
shock they're defending backpage.com
because they haven't done this
sufficient research at best again it's
it's pretty astonishing that they would
go so far as to defend a site that
apparently is involved in child sex
trafficking but I guess that we're
supposed to believe that only Trump
voters are deplorable okay well we will
be back here tomorrow with all the
latest i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alec singhara audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018